in this G engine tutorial we are
learning how to use the built-in draw
function to create custom shapes for 2D
user interfaces and games while the G
engine has nodes that you can create
Sprites polygons particles a bunch of
other things when you need to create
something that those nodes don't provide
you can actually manually draw on the
screen using the built-in draw commands
this can be useful when you want to
create specific shapes or objects or a
whole bunch of objects on the screen
when creating a high amount of nodes
would actually hurt performance or
creating custom UI controls the draw
function is available in any canvas item
based class node so this includes all of
the control nodes and node 2D nodes
we're going to start by creating a basic
Circle first create a new 2D scene with
a node 2D parent next add a new node 2D
node as a child and name it Circle add a
new script to the circle node and add
the following lines the draw function is
where we'll place our custom drawing
logic and this is a built-in G function
and by adding it to our script we are
overwriting the default logic with
whatever we put in there the Q redraw
function is going to be placed within
our process function and we need that to
manually tell the engine to redraw every
single frame now the drawing logic that
we put in the draw function comes from a
number of built-in drawing functions for
a range of purposes I'm going to link to
those in the description but to
summarize you can draw shapes texts
strings Primitives polygons a whole
bunch of things including textures right
there in your drawing function to add
our Circle go to the draw function and
add the draw Circle function within our
draw Circle function we have a number of
parameters that determine properties of
our Circle including position radius
color whether or not it's filled a width
of the line if it's not and whether we
use anti-aliasing for our test we're
going to create a solid red circle using
this code with our code in place we can
test this by running our scene and you
should see a red circle in the upper
left corner of the screen let's make it
a little bit easier to see that and move
that to the middle of the screen we're
going to use our screen center and to
get that we get the viewport size and
divide that in half then we can plug
that into the position of our draw
Circle function you can add any number
of commands within the draw function so
let's go ahead and add a line after we
create our Circle when you run your
scene you should see a red circle and
then a line going up to the 12:00
position now because we're doing this
every single frame within the process
function it also means that we can
dynamically change those properties of
our drawing functions to actually
animate our drawings or have them
dynamically React to what the player is
doing for our test we're going to have
our line rotate around the circle like
it's the hand of a clock to do this we
need to adjust the end point of our draw
line so that the point rotates around
the center of the circle we do that by
multiplying the Circle radius that we
set with a cosine and S as we create a
sum of time using our Delta each frame
time increases by our Delta or the time
between our frames and then we get the S
and cosine of time to simulate the end
point moving around the circle and just
by using a few lines of code we've
actually created a custom clock graphic
that we can easily adjust its size color
and shape and while this example is
really basic you can use this draw
function to create Graphics that are
very very responsive to your code
opening up a lot of possibilities for UI
and 2D graphics
[Music]